hello I'm gav I'm Dan we're the slow-mo
guys back out on the firing range trying
to skip bullets off the surface of this
here water yeah if you didn't know that
happens it does it can be quite
dangerous if you're shooting near water
so you've got to be careful because it
can take a Ricochet and just sort of
Bounce everywhere which is uh quite
dangerous so we've wedged this tank up
against the sand bank so that anything
that does bounce goes straight into the
sand and uh what this is some like
sandbags and stuff to sort of protect
the tank in case I miss and hit the
glass and hopefully won't go through too
many fish tanks yeah remember that time
we did uh the 50 cal with Destin we shot
into the pond and the bullet came back
out of the water yeah I remember that
we're going to be using something a lot
smaller than that because we're using a
fish tank a 50 cal wouldn't really be
appropriate so we've got this sort of
small 2-2 which will hopefully be able
to bounce out in the time before it gets
to the end of the tank I think a 50 cal
Landing here would just blow out the
front and back of this tank before it's
even hit the glass yeah it would just
blow out the pressure yeah well I think
this will foreign last two goes I'm I'm
saying one I'm saying I'm just gonna
smash it straight away you think it's
just gonna go yeah I think so all right
well I framed the Phantom up
just in case that happens all right
Perfect all right we're using the
Phantom TMX 7510 we'll start at 82 000
frames a second with an exposure time of
about six microseconds should be enough
for a nice sharp bullet this is my
prediction by the way
either can I get two options yeah either
I'm going to miss wildly and it's going
to come in about here and smash through
the glass at the back yeah end of the
tank or I'll get it kind of like here
it'll go underwater a little bit and
then kick off about and come out like
here yeah I wonder if this tank is long
enough this might be ambitious this
might be ambitious yeah I think maybe I
want to change my prediction to one
you can't it's too late ah all right
where's Focus the biggest Grill I've
ever seen in my life
monster
all right eyes and ears on loaded
taking off safe
oh I got ricochet
it worked are you serious yeah did you
see it hitting the sand I did oh wow it
kicks out quite a bit of water actually
all right let's have a watch I wonder
where I hit it and how long it takes we
should measure
the the people whoa damn
close it was kind of tumbled wow it
skimmed not very far not far at all wow
that's amazing look how look at that
angle that must have been like it was
well it's difficult to tell to be honest
I just had to aim at the front because I
didn't want to smash the back yeah and
it really nearly hit the front of it so
it probably traveled like half the
length but you wouldn't want to you
probably wouldn't want to start any
later than the halfway point no you're
right
we get closer up
yeah well done on the uh I'm not
shooting the fish tank yeah thanks
we need a new tripod that's not gummed
up with like eggs and paint and uh got
my nails that one okay thermite
yeah right
oh hang on there's a bullet here
is that it might be the one
I went far it went far all right so I
need a little bit more depth to try and
get more in Focus but the Sun
behind a lot of clouds so I'm just going
to pop this very bright LED under the
tank laying straight up so it should
have a
should look pretty cool but it's just
going to look a bit odd it's not going
to look very natural yeah yeah okay you
ready yep
also if you break the tank on this one
we won't see it
okay all right ready yeah cover it
oh
there she goes in
and out straight as an arrow perfect in
the middle that one didn't tumble out it
just I think the angle was so so flat it
would just like glanced it it didn't
even flip I wonder if it's the shape of
the bullet that's allowing it to do that
it's almost perfectly shaped for doing
it
that was great that really is amazing
see the rifling coming in yeah flexion
oh it's so consistent I wonder how much
it slowed it down though we should
measure the speed at before and
afterwards yeah both it's got to be
significant slow down so we got the sun
we've got lights and I thought instead
of just using a regular 2-2 round like
up until we've been doing now which is
like a just a lead slug looks like that
in the base
we've also got some red tip Tracer
rounds they're slightly larger and
longer and that's because they need to
incorporate Within
a little pyrotechnic mixture that's uh
ignited when you fired around
a little bit front on now
ready
might have missed where you're shooting
the way you're aiming though that you
did be by Miles
you shot so immensely early really
whoa Jesus
yeah I'm trying to avoid doing that
you'll see that Trace
oh sweet that's good
oh wow you can see the little Tracer
makes it so much easier to see doesn't
it yeah even during the day it's a
pretty good shot to use these because I
like that the Splash in the sand happens
before the Splash and the water's even
finished splashing yeah wow it's burning
boss it is really bright whoa look at
you can see it just spinning off in the
distance oh yeah look it leaves behind a
trail of burning pyro is that because
the impact is like not dislodged it a
little bit well you can see there's no
Trail there's no like burning Trail to
speak of is there behind him maybe a
little bit I'll tell you what we can't
tell from this angle just because it's
so shallow yeah we should go back to a
maybe just a wider straight on with this
type of bullet I am noticing something
that's happening where the bullet is
just above the water it's disturbing in
a quite interesting way
yeah and we also want to see the trace
around sort of better exposed
undisturbed ready yep
so there are little Flames like burnt
propelling coming out the back it looks
like a little miniature rocket doesn't
it manages to stale it underwater by the
looks of it well I mean the water's
barely touching it and because I am
assuming the pyrotechnic element has its
own source of oxygen it doesn't really
matter although has it gone out I think
it went out I think when it tumbles it
basically gets flooded with water and
maybe that just dislodges all the
propellant I've seen it definitely seen
it before when I've been shooting into
this water so far it's been staying lit
so maybe the bounces the glances are
more propellant friendly I have noticed
that it is kicking more water out than
the regular ball rounds maybe that's
because of the way the bullets weighted
yeah that they tumbling more which is
causing more of a more displacement but
why don't we do our mirror shot then
with this okay that was a great shot
well placed me excuse me all right now
in order to get an angle from underneath
without getting the camera splashed we
are filming off this mirror how's it
look murky a bit murky isn't it yeah
real murky is this dust in this Quarry I
think it just immediately coats
everything in a light blanket of crap we
might see something though yeah ready as
chuff
yeah
probably if we run out of water I can
just towel myself off
wring it out
making a crown
doing something brown
it was too early
whoa out humbles in there look it like
goes back with
it too yeah so it went like propellant
down yeah
weird I guess that's how it hits the
water isn't it how much look how much
disturbance it makes compared to the
size of the bullet it's mental such a
transference of energy yeah and just
water being completely incompressible
it's just like yeah yeah yeah all right
uh
what would a nine mil do
I think that would do a lot more damage
should we find out I think we should
find out because on this channel when
stuff goes wrong it still looks right
if anything looks better okay if
camera's further back because the tank
has a high chance of going and this will
be a nine mil pistol round I also
haven't got my eye in for the Target yet
so I don't know where I'm going to try
and aim to hit it about here but it
could be anywhere all right
I've only got like an inch above the
surface there's mainly the tank on this
one
all right loaded
made ready
safe it left just lived but uh it
bounced the bullet just clean bounced it
amazing Honestly though I got showered
here
what
there are so many times where I just
can't contain
I couldn't even save that without going
all right okay uh we've got for me yeah
I'm ready
oh
just tumbled in the tank wow
what the
plink oh
what what
oh you shot the inside of a glass
aquarium with a pistol and it slowed
down so much it didn't break
shook the heck out of it but you just
shot a window with a bullet so weird it
must have slowed it down the perfect
amount to Just Bounce Off it bounced off
the bottom he still had enough force
that it it was you could basically see
it like a Trail of Light like it's like
perfect wow I like that the air bubbles
are going downwards while the bullet is
still going downwards it makes it look
like we're upside down like the bubbles
are floating it's a strong tank it just
turned the bullet it just goes nope now
you're going that way
the fact that it's still moving fast
enough to cavitate the water it must
still be traveling at serious speed that
glass is freakish wow I I couldn't have
hit it more perfectly either did you see
where it entered the the tank right at
the back I gave it as much chance as
possible to to bounce maybe it just
needs a tighter angle I'm so surprised
it went in just didn't bounce
I'm blown away so let's inspect what
happened if you'd have if you'd have
said right any money where's the bullet
gonna end up I wouldn't have said at the
back of the front of the tank here yeah
it's just parked at the back there so
the nine mil round displaced more water
than my arm is worth because I'm not
spilling any extra water out that is
such a good visualization isn't it isn't
it yeah sure all right let's see how
much of me the nine mil
was it good
I don't believe I believe it I don't
believe it
look at the bullet yeah regular bullet
Boop that's what the tank did to it and
if we wanted to know the angle on the
bullet that it hit the the window we can
get it we have it recorded we could use
measurements on the bullet itself look
it's like split the FMJ there around the
around the soft lead
on the glass if anything there's nothing
there's I don't see a single mark
well anything either there's no it's
just it's just survived it do you want
to see how much that little nine mil
round in my pocket
here this how much water this displaced
yeah and we gotta remember that that
won't be entirely accurate because some
of the water would have landed back at
the tank anyway that's true that's true
let's try it shall we so I'm going to
put my entire arm in
there we go so basically your entire
forearm and halfway up your bicep
this is this is how we should measure if
I start going to the gym come back and
do the same thing and then suddenly I
only get this much in that's a good way
to measure some gains or even bulk it up
yeah yeah
my left arm just goes all the way in
it might get to the point where we're
just putting the Phantom right behind
the glass and trusting it
hey that's down to you definitely not
oh yes as I suspected it just fully
caught it fully just contained so that
means that the angle I shot it
is too steep to bounce it
but the tank is big enough to withstand
it so there's enough water in there for
it to travel through to slow it down
before it hits the back correct so to
break it you'd have to shoot it closer
to the back I'd have to shoot it over
here oh it's like shedding some of its
Trails weird yeah
it's the same exact thing in it yeah
it's too steep
oh see how the cavitation is already
collapsing there yeah that's much slower
than the nightmare much smaller and
slower yeah that was much less of an
impact didn't even bounce that much
interesting right so if our predictions
are correct this one will be much less
deformed yeah but actually no it has
deformed I've just spotted something
there's a flat surface
to the bullet if you look here you hit
on the side it hit on the side so we're
still going with some decent clip then
yeah it was going at some clip but
obviously not as much as the nine mil
and that's deformed the you know Cooper
nickel Full Metal Jacket there whereas
this one's just the sort of lead
internal and it's deformed it slightly
and flattened it um sorry if you're
watching and all that was out of focus I
can't actually see the screen because
it's so bright out here but hopefully I
got some of it do you want to try again
yeah give me some and you can see the
engaging in the rifling as well yeah oh
well I love it when we see something we
don't expect and I didn't expect that to
happen with the bullet for a start
didn't expect to see consistently
bouncing bullets pretty much all the
time yeah and then the one bumped off
there sort of makes sense when you think
about the deceleration but you just
don't expect to see it like when after
watching it bounce so many times I was
like there's no way the bullets in there
no that must have meant that it hit the
glass with such Force to deform the
bullet but it didn't break the glass you
know in like Star Trek where they're
like oh she said 98 like Integrity I
wonder what percentage more power you'd
need to smash the glass there yeah we
probably used up 97 of Integrity there
yeah I think it was like oh yeah yeah
when you're playing those games where
there's like Bridge making and the
stress is all it goes from like green to
red and you're like it would have been
bright red like oh
um we clearly watch a lot of content and
play a lot of games all right we'll
quite everything to that hopefully you
enjoyed that video we had a ton of fun
making it we've got a second Channel
we've got some merch that was pretty old
you can still buy it there
and we'll see you next time thank you
very much for watching bye